the trailer for Olaf's frozen adventure
just dropped and gives us a cool sneak
peek at the new Disney animated mini
movie starring frozen snowman yippie Kay
movie lovers it's Jan here and I'm
excited to see that while we wait for
frozen to Disney will be treating us to
a 21 minute short film or featurette
that brings back for a holiday special
all our favourite frozen characters
including Elsa on a Kristoff Sven and
Olaf so in this video I'm going to be
analyzing the new trailer and revealing
some cool frozen and Disney Easter eggs
to some other little details you might
have missed when the frozen filmmaking
team began dreaming up stories for the
first frozen themed short film frozen
fever many of their initial ideas
actually focused on Olaf the snowman of
course in the end they turned their
attention to Elsa and Anna instead but
that is clear from the title and trailer
for Olaf's frozen adventure the
filmmaking team have decided to put the
friendly snowman very much as a friends
and center of their storytelling yet
again speaking of frozen fever there are
some nice little parallels between that
short and this new one
freeze ample both stories Centre on
family celebrations and traditions with
frozen fever being all about birthday
festivities while Olaf's frozen
adventure is all about the holiday
season in fact in this new short film
Elsa and her sister will be celebrating
this particular holiday for the first
time since they were reunited also both
short films feature characters on the
hunt for something around arendelle in
frozen fever Elsa sent her sister on a
scavenger hunt for birthday gifts while
this new film sees Olaf on the hunt for
holiday traditions so he can celebrate
the season with Elsa and her sister who
are a part so long that you don't have
any family traditions of their own by
the way on the subject of family the
family portrait we see in the trailer is
actually an original piece of concept
art for the movie frozen during Olaf's
adventure we see him enjoying finding
out about the different ways families
mark the holidays and there's a very
funny Easter Egg for wreck-it Ralph when
he grabs the candy cane and uses it to
replace his carrot nose exclaiming sugar
rush in the first wreckit-ralph movie
Ralph enters a go-kart racing candy
filled game called sugar rush which
features a candy cane forest where he
meets vanellope
wreck-it Ralph - is actually Disney's
next animated movie so it's cool that
they added a little nod to it here as
they also did in Moana
also a touch of adult here in this
moment as well as the way Olaf's eyes
spin reminded me of the reaction of the
main characters in movies like Pinocchio
in the good dinosaur when they got
rather different rushes one of the
festive traditions Olaf learns about in
the scene you can see here is the feast
of Saint Lucia which in a number of
Nordic countries like the ones that
inspired the frozen movies is celebrated
on the 13th of December and includes a
girl typically wearing a white gown and
red sash together with a wreath of
candles on her head and as you can see
from this play olaf collects quite a few
gifts on his travels with fen and hidden
in this shot of the sleigh the green toy
is a little tuft of reddish pink hair
which could be a nod to Elliot from
Pete's dragon and you can also just make
out what looks like a troll which is a
callback to the trolls in the original
frozen movie and to the 12 statues
outside oaken store and it looks like
Olaf will be paying a visit to oaken's
sauna in this short film - which makes
sense as although it's a different
season here we know from Olaf's in
summer songs that he likes the idea of
letting off steam
in fact Olaf's frozen adventure doesn't
just link very nicely back to Disney's
previous frozen tales but according to
John Lasseter who's chief creative
officer at Disney and Pixar Animation
Studios it also fits in perfectly with
frozen - which is due out in cinemas in
November 2019
indeed as laughs as at old ewu could sit
down and watch Olaf's frozen adventure
and frozen - as one big marathon which
makes it sound like this latest tale
really is part of the building blocks
for the much anticipated frozen sequel
which will follow the lives of Elsa and
her sister after the events of this new
short of course one of the mega popular
parts of the frozen movies are their
insanely catchy songs for frozen and
frozen fever those tunes were written by
husband-and-wife team Robert Lopez and
Kristen anderson-lopez this time though
there's a new songwriting Bureau in the
kingdom Kate Anderson and ELISA Sampson
and they've written four original songs
for the new mini movie and in case
you're wondering the track key here in
the trailer is called when were together
and notice how as the sisters sing the
song Elsa seems to be sending Olaf up
into the air with a star that has a mini
snowman figure frozen inside it and did
Olaf put the same star on top of the
this tree here by the way the look of
the tree and the snowflake shape
underneath makes me think that Elsa has
fashioned this tree herself out of ice
in a similar way to how she made an ice
sculpture for her sister's birthday in
frozen fever
although Olaf's frozen adventure was
initially going to make its debut on TV
now it's going to premiere on the big
screen in front of pixels animated movie
Coco in a similar way to how the short
film frozen fever first screened in
front of Disney's live-action movie
Cinderella and it's interesting that
both Olaf's frozen adventure and Coco
share a common theme of family
traditions centered around big
celebrations with Olas adventure
focusing on the December holidays and
Coco on the day of the dead by the way
to find out lots more about Coco hit the
top right of the screen to watch my
video on kicks arse new movie now how
excited are you for
Olaf's frozen adventure and what would
you like to see happen in frozen 2 let
me know in the comments below and if you
enjoyed this do please hit that like
button and tap the screen to check out
more of my other Disney Animation videos
including cool facts you might not know
about frozen fever thanks for watching
and see you next time
yippie Kay movie lovers